in diesem video werden wieder einige
geheimnisse bei clixoom gelüftet unter
anderem was x-men mit den fähigkeiten
von culcha candela zu tun hat was sie
über frauen denken und was ihr
erfolgsgeheimnis ist und noch viel viel
mehr und wenn er nichts verpassen wollt
mit culcha candela dann was wir genau da
oben abonnieren nicht vergessen zu
drücken also bleibt dran bis dann
sensation etwas auf wir haben wieder
geguckt was sind die gemeinsten fragen
immer euch fragen kann und was sind die
nettesten fragen die man fragen kann es
sind irgendwie mehr gemeine fragen
geworden das sind die roten fragen und
ihr dürft ziehen jeder darf wer loch in
der reihe ihr könnt benzin ihr könnt
auch ein problem grünes harmlos rot ist
gemein
ist ihnen wissen muss gemeinsam
ihr könnt ja auch mal was auch immer
erst aufmachen beantworten dann der
nächste
und ich haben sich nicht alle
gleichzeitig der reihe nach auf erste
frau ihr sehen so viel grüne
machen wir gleich noch
aber ab träger oder so
ja immer wieder von hand
bohrhammer schon wieder ein hit-album
wie macht sie das bloß
wenn wir das wüssten wir machen einfach
immer weiter ja habt ihr kein einfacher
job kein erfolg
wie also erfolgsrezept ist
hat hammer so eine dna sagt man ja heute
wo man sagt ich muss das machen das
jetzt kennt ihr den den vier akkorde
song im internet ja eine klemme wer
wirklich toll funktioniert haben
es gibt schon ein paar merkmale auf die
man achten kann und sollte und wenn aber
die sind nicht immer ein garant dafür
dass es auch klappt sonst wäre es ja ein
bisschen langweilig und so wurde jeder
hits machen aber wäre natürlich auch ein
paar geheimnisse die wir jetzt nicht wir
verraten können und die werden auch
regelmäßig angewandt okay aus welchem
bereich kommen die geheimnisse denn
der philosophie
der probleme frauen an zu machen oder
warum sind ja immer darüber
die sage ich sage nein nein ich probleme
frauen an zu machen sondern frauen sind
so wichtig für uns dass wir sie immer so
vergöttern halt und deswegen sind wir
immer für sie damit die den respekt und
die die
den wert ja bekommen was sie verdienen
halt die frauen sind die erde von der
menschheit so deswegen ist super wissen
wir derzeit den quasi wurde am 1
wir haben den hammer
applaus mit
sehr schön ist wissen wir kultivieren
war war
warum seid ihr so
konnte ich muss das einfach weitergeben
das kompliment ich kann gar nichts dafür
bedanke mich mit meinen eltern und den
gehen und bei euch dass ihr uns toll
findet wenn also
genau und ich frage mich auch jeden
morgen
warum eigentlich was soll das ganze
ich möchte an dieser stelle michael
wendler als argumentationshilfe
heranbringen er steht jeden tag vom
spiel und sagt ich bin toll
ja also noch bei noch besser ist ja zu
wissen was seine schwächen sind das will
ich ja dazu zu stehen doch damit
offensiv umzugehen deswegen meine
schwäche ist einfach dass ich mich toll
finde
danke
superstimmung denken wir jetzt wieder
böse frage
meint ihr das wirklich
ernst mit
gutmenschentum
böse frage wie diese frage ist
übernehmen nicola ist es muss überlegen
so manchen wir es ernst migros bitte
nicht so weit weg ich überlege noch ja
ja
ich würde sagen es ist eine bescheuerte
frage und wir kriegen ein bescheuerter
antwort wie meine es wirklich ernst auf
jeden fall wir sind wirklich so stock im
arsch ich unterwegs in unseren texten
immer daherkommen und ja wir denken dass
wir diese welt verbessern und
verschönern können und dafür arbeiten
wir jeden tag ein kleines bisschen
von daher ja auf jeden fall meinen wir
das ernst nehmen und dabei vielleicht
nicht zu ernst das ist glaube ich das
entscheidende dass man das ganze auch
mit einem augenzwinkern tut und nicht
wie so ein studienrat da steht denn
irgendwie alles schon immer und cool
fanden aber in der sache glaube ich nein
wir das schon so wie wir es sagen und
tun
das war ohne frage das war wie kino ist
sie halt immer dass mike bitte wenn ich
werde jetzt hier eine nicht ganz so
diese fragen geben
mal auch so wie ihr mit
22 zeitige gut gemeinte frage vierte
position zwei zeilen vor diese technik
mit oben oder sozusagen zwei zeilen
gleichzeitig irgendwie euch denken hier
vielleicht mal absicht dann rot hier
macht seid ihr immer das noch gute
freunde
nach sehr langer zeit wie also nochmal
in einer zeile
ich es nicht verstanden
es ist ja ihr seid immer noch gute
freunde nach sehr langer zeit wie macht
ihr das
das ist die frage die gut gemeinte frage
das ist eigentlich eigentlich ist diese
frage weil das setzt voraus dass es so
ist aber in dem fall
in dem fall kann ich wirklich auch guten
gewissens sagen dass es tatsächlich so
gut ist also so ein gutes verhältnis
herrscht und zwar liegt es daran dass
wir uns eben in der länge der zeit auch
tatsächlich sehr gut kennengelernt haben
und tatsächlich auch wissen wie der
andere drauf ist was den anderen so
umtreibt wie man gerade tickt und wenn
man sich vielleicht aus dem weg gehen
sollte oder was man vielleicht
einfach nur körperliche gewalt sprechen
aber
auf jeden fall es ist tatsächlich so
dass wir uns und das können wir guten
müssen sagen alle respektieren und das
ist glaube ich die basis davon dass man
sich
respektvoll gegenseitig begegnet und
manchmal auch mit respekt körperliche
züchtigung auf jeden fall mögen wir uns
und es ist schon fast täglich nach so
langer zeit
und so passt auf wir noch vier fragen
wollte die noch ja
da gibt es oft
noch zwei übrig nochmal ihr müsst euch
der letzte muss ich eine ausdenken
muss sich eine ausdenken
ich muss ich muss lanfang
flatrate optimiert kann man so stehen
ein 1 1 1 1 naja ist so steht ihr
flatrate optimiert ist der titel ihres
neuen albums
suchmaschinen optimiert gut gedacht gut
gedacht mitgebracht
ich verstehe die frage überhaupt nicht
denn das heißen natürlich ist die
natürliche
suchmaschinenoptimiert ganz klar wir
haben ja extra eine extra neue deutsche
neue deutsche schreibweise gewählt damit
man definitiv wenn man flatrate 1 gibt
so wie es ihr da spricht in deutschland
also mit dann kommt man zwangsläufig bei
unserem album raus also ja ist es
definitiv optimiert besucher
nutzen konsumentenfreundlich
nutzerfreundlich wir haben es einfach
den leuten angebot leichter gemacht aber
ich finde ehrlich gesagt man kann die
frage doch kurz fassen also in der frage
steckt so ein bisschen die antwort ich
mach das mal wieder zusammen flatrate
optimiert
ich werde gleich weiter dann muss die
kamera nämlich nicht winken
hier nicht
mal was originelles machen
richtig böse frage die auch ein bisschen
verletzend ist also ich muss sagen es
ist es geht auch geht auch wirklich tief
ich muss darüber erst mal kurz
nachdenken
wollte nicht mal was originelles machen
also hör mal zu freundin wir machen was
verdammt originelles und zwar jedes mal
und wir haben das gefühl dass wir
wirklich jedes mal was neues machen und
das ist tatsächlich ernst gemeint und
wenn du es nicht auch gelaufen ist dann
geh doch nach hause und mache was
originelles
wie kommt sie kommt zum schluss
erscheint die lieber als wie genau die
entjungferung geht sie zurück in ihre
heimat
nein das sehe ich
das nicht okay okay
ein paar sachen da würde ja stehen wie
wie seid ihr auf euren namen gekommen
ihr seid zu sechst
habt ihr es alleine nicht draufhauen
so jetzt etwas gutes
gibt es schon etliche jahre warum habt
ihr immer noch einen solchen erfolg
ich sage mal so das ist wahr es gibt
seit sehr vielen jahren aber das jahr
voll kam dass wir erfolg haben das liegt
an unsere fans und wir haben so ein ein
erfolgreiches jahr bisher zu einer
vollgas bis jetzt gehabt wegen unserer
fans und deswegen noch mal danke an alle
fans da draußen alle leute die uns
unterstützen und weiter so und dann
machen wir weiter so also vielen dank